partir à la découverte des steppes
mongoles vivre l'aventuré jusque dans la
yourte mais restait en plein coeur de
l'auvergne
cette famille de voyage en breton n'est
pas loin d'avoir trouvé la recette des
raccourcis des halles
un peu d'exotisme tout en ayant un
certain confort et pour ne rien oublier
pélagie a décidé de consigner ses
souvenirs et tout s'est rempli malgré
une cascade une cascade les arts verts
ah et puis avec la fourmilière aussi
c'est l'année dernière qu'un tour
operator a décidé de planter ses hôtes
anti turque en lozère convaincu d'y
retrouver la même décor qu en mongolie
c'est tout un monde où nation de
prairies il ya des grosses formations de
blocs de granit et c'est surtout des
ciels parce que les ciels sont assez
blanc mais il est plein de l'aubrac ne
sont passés de mongolie tout du cynisme
j'ai pas l'intention de proposer la
mongolie en france ça n'existe pas enfin
petit un petit rappel donc peut-être
partiront-ils les prochaines années dans
ce pays magnifique pour les convaincre
il a confié ses voyageurs achir jeune
étudiante mongole et guides d'un été
l'hôtesse a sorti son meilleur atout la
cuisine traditionnelle
alors ça s'appelle bosse en montgolfière
raviolis et 100 ch souvent pour la fête
et pour l'un grandes occasions
les vols affection au coeur mais voilà
prêt à partir